hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now that
I've gotten over the horror of what I
had to do I'm gonna move on and then I'm
probably gonna have sex with an alien
and that's gonna be totally okay with me
for some strange reason but a cat that's
a no-no I am weird so don't blame me I
am also very creepy so why don't you
just let me do what I do and then I'm
gonna be okay okay all right I think
that Tiffany's at level four Tiffany's
mom is at level three Nikki oh I've
almost completely ignored Nikki I gotta
go see her Nikki ash Nikki's asleep well
this doesn't help me at all so who do I
have the most I think Lola actually has
the most Funi potential so if I go shut
up I am busy so if I go suck some honey
out of Lola then I should be able to do
what I need to do oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah I thought I was gonna end this game
with a perfect score but apparently I'm
not gonna do it oh yeah she doesn't have
any more unique stuff so everything here
is good when you buy anymore you my
inventory is 100% full oh my god they've
got too much underwear okay so now I
need to go say hi to Jessi bye bye
thanks for all the hooni I just need a
little more upgrade and then I'm gonna
be able to never lose again actually if
I just plan out my encounters that I
would never actually like so much she
want to sit on Santa's lap okay I love
this picture from a big game a couple
weeks ago I look so cute oh good for you
who took the picture who is this close
to the cheerleaders anyway all right I
have no idea I'm gonna give you more
boos thank you thank you thank you
where's the martini there it is okay
thank you okay it's Jim it doesn't need
bottle service we've been over this
before
uh-huh sure of course you have it that
makes obviously clear sense I did not
plan out my thing
[ __ ] she likes sexuality hello baby
[Music]
dance your baby I'm your baby on the
baby on the baby I'm your baby no I'm
gonna do it exactly one more time and
then I'm never gonna talk to you ever
again because I have an alien to get to
thank you very much bye bye bye now
would you ever consider going through
the back door oh I want to answer that
but I need the hooni how many
invitations are you writing out whoa
whoa easy there all right so it's time a
lien time time for aliens I don't know
why I'm so excited about this one but
this one in particular I'm actually very
excited about I don't know why I like
this alien I played a drone I ho threw
up the war craft hello oh you're so glad
would you like some earthling booze
it's night time when do you want your
booze that's fine what you're in totally
good with me fine by me
fine by me totally fine 100 percent okay
[Music]
okay are you okay does that hurt
[ __ ] you all right what happened to you
never mind
you know what some things are better
left to the imagination even though that
suit leaves absolutely nothing to be
imagination
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa well what what like a dog
I guess she's an alien
louder oh god is that actually the sound
from the movie aliens okay that sounded
like a straight-up goat okay I'm not oh
no I'm not okay with this that sounded
that was 100% go right there
I'm almost positive thousand an alien
mark please put your Earth Penniston my
alien holes yes mark senpai I like the
earth Venice I love the earth panis now
you
[Music]
okay yee-whoo alrighty then
well okay that's um what I've been
looking forward to this whole time
goodbye goodbye Celeste you alien Beauty
have not said hi to Nikki this entire
time but don't know why it's just been
very not approaching of Nikki hello hi
how are you you good good who I have a
thing
hey cutie this is for you it's my from a
cam show last night the boys are a big
fan of that toy they also keep asking me
to put a shoe on my head oh good old
4chan oh is that a drawing deliverable
the rudl I'll see you later I guess I
need to go ask this girl on a date now
what does she like talent Hey okay date
me day me shut up date me just date me
come on another successful date by the
market pooper can't be beaten as far as
the eye can see
yes sure did that's what you get a good
date for under estimating me hope you
don't do it again how dare you alright
time to finish this and by finish this I
mean sleep with Jessie and then go brag
about it to Tiffany that's gonna be
weird then again I had sex with a cat
and an alien and then everyone else on
the planet so I mean this can't be that
weird if I sleep with everyone
someone's related to someone that's not
so weird okay I'm good are you good I'm
good let's get some honey I guess I
don't need much more honey
that I got it I'm good
[ __ ] yes I finally get the high score on
this stupid game oh cool
who took the picture will be creeping
pictures on who's taking all these
pictures
oh well also who's taking the pictures
at the end of the pictures you have
awfully plain underwear for your
occupation never mind
Oh yours marking new put your furnishing
my butt oh yes oh yes oh yes oh yes oh
yes oh yes xxx oh yes pandas pandas HHH
HHH yes sex I'm the best oh hey how's it
going good to see you there thanks for
stopping by
good bye ok why don't I feel good about
myself
you'd think that I would feel good but
maybe all this endless conquest isn't
filling up the empty void in my heart
and what I really need is a meaningful
relationship where I stay with one woman
I can be your official plaything in this
sleep with her daughter haha ok so thank
you everybody so much for watching as
always I will see you
[Music]
[Applause]